welcome to this video pink yeah this is
a new video in a series coming the
tournament that I played on my Yorker
this is the third round coverage and
this is now a very very serious opponent
after winning the first two games um
only a couple of players were left with
two out of two so I am was part of the
bottom half of this player group in
terms of rating so I got a much better
opponent this time and yeah I got the
black pieces against him annoys Ascanius
that's a pretty well known grandmaster
from Lithuania he's rated 2547 so um
pretty solid Grandmaster his some in
this that rating ranged for I don't know
20 years or something and I know him for
for ages at least from from looking at
his games not personally he's some I
think I guess around 50 years old so a
veteran of the tournament circuit so
let's see what happened in this game he
played one default yes he usually does
however when I prepared for the game I
wasn't totally sure what he would play
because right here he had played
numerous numerous systems he had played
mostly neither three but also g3 and 93
so basically all moves that that are
played here all main moves and it was
very tough to guess it would have been
very funny if he played an idea three
because then I would have played the
BOGO the opening that I'm looking at in
my book that is in the works and the
funny thing in this would would have
been that twine is in fact as the
world's leading expert on the BOGO line
that I'm choosing in the book my book
contains numerous exam
both of his play so it would have been
funny to play that but it didn't happen
he played Knight c3 so we got animals oh
and he went for e3 yeah he had played
that before but only I know very limited
amount of games so I couldn't this
wasn't very high on my list let's say of
things that I expected and well this is
one of them lines that have only
recently worked on for the for the
manuscript of the book so I was pretty
confident that I at least should know
something okay we play this this line
normally called the Huebner variation
with 96 and the capture here and now d6
yeah that's a line that is known pretty
much since the early days of the
nimzo-indian in fact even news which
himself had to have played this way but
there was never really a name attached
to this a particular set up until Robert
OOP not the leading German Grand Master
of the 70s and 80s picked it up in the
early seventies and then it was named
Huebner variation there's also
well-known game in the legendary 1972
World Championship match between Fischer
and Spassky where this line was played
by Fisher and I can show you how this
this went because we we follow this
example the the Fischer Spassky game was
pass key Fischer's passed it was white
was a bit different because fish I had
not cancelled but and it can easily
transpose D 597 yeah in this certain
position
Spassky almost this position Spassky had
played the move Knight h4 up to that day
this is still the main news and I
actually believe that it is why it's
best rhyme it wasn't playing played in
this game here by Kiwanis he chosen
differ
different plan goodnight h4 is a good
move
the idea is that blacks main plan in
this in this line is to play later f5 so
black will move this night away
somewhere mostly to e8 and then go f5
and night h4 is immediately playing
against this idea the other ideas that
it frees up the the f-pawn ended allows
Queen f3
after that h6 is the main movement here
the way Spassky plate was f4 which was
answered by 96 special we got this very
interesting pawn formation which was a
really revelation at the time that this
formation is actually good for black not
like like it's better but the totally
fine formation also really AM yeah it
amazed lots of people back then nowadays
it is some pretty much common knowledge
yeah so this is a bit of history of the
line twine it split 91
the idea is comparable he wants to have
the F pawn push at the right moment the
knight urn can relocate like this well
after g3 via g2 III or g2 h form there
are ideas like that and it also the main
point is really to to make the F pawn
free yeah I remembered that when I
worked at the book that this was a
serious move but um I mostly I
remembered okay 98 is to be played very
logical anyway and I I played that
rather quickly and he played Queen c2
which is a move that has been played
before but when I looked at this line in
the book I remember that g4 was an
interesting move played by nakamura very
early game by Nakamura from 2003 when he
was just 16 years old
just playing against their fire this is
rather interesting yeah okay but I don't
want to be so thorough in the opening
because there was many interesting
things later
yeah Quincy 2 makes lots of sense it
looks at this a 5-pound f5 point and in
fact if I now play f5 he will play f4 a
typical kind of counter stroke and after
that it's not very comfortable for black
I think f5 is mistimed the problem is
that he's basically threatening to take
on e5 and that cannot recapture with the
piece I don't really want to recapture
with a pawn and yeah there are various
problems if I take for example Bishop
takes there is this giant immediate
threat so I cannot really prevent him to
take and yeah something like that it's
also not ideal yeah that it this is
playable it's not terrible but the thing
is I think I have a much more precise
move I played h6 here and this is just
better because f5 is still in the mix
him playing f4 just like that it's not
really leading to much because here I
get good control over he 5 you know the
Knight is guarding this important spot
and I can might be that's a bit much I
might be able to even get the other
night involved into this 5 square fight
therefore is not good so he basically
expected the move now g3 is the move
that makes most sense
it supports f4 and they last night in
the night to come to g2 yeah now I
played f5 a 3 thought there is no point
in waiting anymore and it seems to be ok
he went f4 very logical white can also
take but F was just more testing this
shouldn't be a big problem I thought
this is the relatively best way to play
and
I can also play Bishop h3 with no
particular problem also a reason why
waiting for g3 is a good idea you have
this this additional possibility so on
f5 he played F form as expected
yeah idea yeah I just I just had a
really really a brain slip a brain slip
not at all slip a brain slip and I
thought okay well I need to take on both
I need to check out f1 I need to take on
e4 yeah um basically something like that
was was my idea on its aim to get this
position and then Knight f6 and I
actually thought okay it's no it's
absolutely doesn't matter how in which
order I take like taking here first or
taking on e4 first in fact it is a big
difference and I completely missed that
it is easy to Fritz here F takes e4 is
much better this is quite comfortable
for black for example
after Bishop f4 I had intended Knight f6
with a decent game but even g5 is
possible this is was pointed out by the
computer afterwards and this that didn't
really look at in the game maybe when
when we reached it on the board because
I mean this is very comfortable for me I
get an additional tempo later
and this age 65 is not a serious
weakness I can I can easily play Knight
f6 here for example and I don't have any
problems I'm very quick with Bishop age
327 rook evade and he cannot really
exploit the weaknesses so this would
have been better because my problem was
I took here and then after some thought
he captured on f5 and I hadn't
absolutely hadn't looked at this move
it's not a big big problem but yeah I
mean I should have seen it so it was a
bit embarrassing yeah yeah I took on g3
which is interesting but probably Bishop
takes a fire
still would have been the the same
choice in a way let's say look at form
Queen d7 I don't think then I have a big
problem the only thing that like I mean
not a big problem is don't think of any
problem and the only thing that like
really must be aware of is the possible
is six weakness here but you always have
Knight c7 to cover six so this this
would have been okay I took on on g3
this does not seem to be a mistake but
it it sharpens the position considerably
and I think it's much more difficult now
for me to play yeah he recaptured with
the pawn of course in 9f six this was my
idea when I captured on g3 to get the
night over to e5 however my um yeah my
judgment here was wasn't wasn't really
really great I think white as chances
for an advantage and we would see rather
quickly that I get into trouble 92 as
expected
94 9h for this was very very logical and
now I went to to e5 maybe black has a
more precise move here but this was just
the idea that that I had when I took on
on g3 gap here here's the first very
critical position of the game it seems
and I absolutely hadn't looked at the
move it seems that the best move here
for white is the move Bishop to e4 this
is pointed out erm by the engine here
Houdini and this is in fact very very
strong the problem is what this might be
now I have have huge problems to to play
this position I'm yeah I'm in a position
where I'm where next space and the
problems I cannot really take on c4
if I ever take then there's f6 coming
and the position opens up to whites
advantage something like that iam it's
not going to end well this is very
similar to the game if you compare this
to the game the problem is that I just
took this e4 pawn which is not really
that important and I am dislocated or I
misplace this knight on c4 which is not
helping in the defense this is in fact a
winning position I mean it's a bit a bit
tough not to to show but if you look at
this white or White's pieces to attack
and in the game I was barely able to to
defend and here white is like two extra
moves so taking on c4 is really really
not great and if I don't take what
exactly am i playing a move like rook f6
for example this is blocking this f6 in
this I mean you can't do that but how
exactly do you continue if white just
plays Bishop and form this is
threatening here on a5 destroying the
structure and if I take here white
pushes g45 this is a tremendous attack
so a very very very tough position
yeah Bishop before is amazingly strong
but while my opponent he played f6
relatively quickly and it's a very
understandable move I mean I
at first when I was looking at this I
really thought I'm in trouble but I had
spotted the defensive setup which in
fact is quite reliable so Bishop before
is much better but it's very tough to to
make that call I took on f6 I must rook
takes GF Bishop f6 this was his idea and
it's a very logical idea with f6 he
opens up all pieces the bishop is opened
up this bishop is taking on h6 quickly
and my King position is not not very
good of course but I have a different
defense here
and founded in disorder couple of moves
earlier and this is Queen d7 this is in
fact a very strong move I mean it's the
only move but it's it still needs to be
found the idea is to get the Queen over
here to to get a counter-attack against
g3 this is whites only problem in the
position his King is also not very safe
and I can always counter-attack the g3
pawn and with it the king this is
important it seems that after Queen d7
Black is okay however it's not easy as
we see immediately afterwards he played
rook everyone yet here I was only
thinking beforehand
okay well Queen d7 I need to play I need
to get to g4 and h3 but I hadn't decided
yet to which square I'm going to put the
Queen to h3 n g4 I was calculating a bit
and well you know we had this rather
quick time control where you only have
19 minutes for the whole game and after
two or three minutes I decided okay just
go with your gut instinct and play Queen
h3 and it turns out that this is a bad
move Queen g4 who was was much better
and we see why in the game it's pretty
it gets pretty pretty obvious but it
still needs to be seen before and okay
he played Bishop f4 and yeah the problem
is that the idea is he threatens to take
and then play Queen f2 to FHM this is
what was played look at look at this
takes and now if if I take with the F
pawn there's Queen f2 and here I'm
totally busted I cannot cover f7 you
know and the difference is if the Queen
would be on g4 instead I have Queen g7 I
can put it on the board just to make it
more clear if we play exactly like that
there should be five bishop
takes takes community of to this isn't a
problem because I can just drop back
yeah and now I'm covering those
sensitive squares and even maybe I can
play rook evade I mean not at the moment
because I push about seven but yeah I
can fight for the FL even so this is
okay for black it is really not not the
problem here and this is the reason why
queen g4 was much better than Queen h4 I
played this and after Bishop f4 it
dawned on me that had done something
rather stupid but okay the thing is what
I overlooked a key move so I thought
that okay maybe Queen g4 was easier but
I wasn't aware of the troubles I'm
already in I mean Bishop e7 I I played
it seems that this was still a bit
tougher defense ninety-three green d39
f5 yeah
this however white can answer with
Bishop d6 pretty pretty funny moves you
haven't thing is I cannot I cannot take
him and because queen g6 will will even
lead to a checkmate in a couple of Musa
and yeah I need to take here and then he
has the funny move Queen e4 and tendon
Queen yet I didn't I didn't see those
ideas I mean the problem was what I
overlooked this I played Bishop d7 here
he took on e5 of course I saw that if I
had gone to g4 I would have been able to
play here yeah this is now just losing
so I played D takes d5 and my problem
was I only saw the move that he actually
played and this is a mistake
funny enough he played Queen f2 it's a
mistake in terms of that there is a
stronger move and we both didn't see it
in this position white can actually win
the game outright with a very strong
move and this is rook f3
that's very strong from just technically
it's very strong it has the idea to play
Queen F
- next yeah just not putting the Queen
on f2 in front of the rook but behind
behind the rook and this is very very
problematic now if black plays for
example rook evade - to cover this
there's d6 and now there's absolutely no
reply now let's say I move the move the
knight
Zach yeah nine to six but this is even
stronger intending Queen h6 and black
can resign
it's a it's really an absolutely deadly
position
another problem is if I go here Queen
Queen g4
then as mentioned there's Queen f2 and
again I have really no no great means if
I cover with rook evade there is d6
which is the strongest reply that's six
and nine and five and this this attack
is totally decisive but Queen look I
have three years amis well if you if you
give it to a computer it will just just
play it out and that's okay you're
winning what's the problem but the thing
is it's very difficult to play in a real
game and he played Queen f2 which also
looks very very attractive but it turns
out that it is not as strong White is
still better yeah but it's not as strong
now I can play rook f8 covering that and
have of course I was totally oblivious
of that I didn't really think see ruk f3
so for me I know I was pretty pretty
satisfied here but yeah it turns out if
white plays correctly he is still better
what he now should do is probably the
move Bishop b4 yeah the idea is to
improve this Bishop a bit maybe use it
to to attack the the Queen and also
white is now threatening something the
moves DC
yeah you want to take this night to get
there five square the problem is what he
did in the game after that
what's my movie a queen g4 I guess and
this is what I saw in the game like
Queen Queen III and then let me look at
my notes yeah this f5 that that can be
tried the problem is I cannot just play
this because these six and now those
kind of night invasions are you have
basically winnings also this moves
possible for example like this I'm sorry
like this because the capture is it's
not not really not really helping this
is too strong yeah this should be fun
it's probably what he knew what he
should have done however he played but
he did this relatively quickly played
the move d6 which really shocked me
because I thought was d6 that that that
cannot be the move really because Bishop
c6 young Islam is the easy to see reply
and I'm pretty sure that he saw them
lose because I mean it's not something
that a strong player would overlook it's
a direct counter threat with mate and
it's occupying the long diagonal he was
certain he saw the move but after I
played Bishop c6 he still took lots of
time to decide what to do next I think
he probably had planned something
against this but but now I'm found out
that the idea that he had had planned
that that it failed somehow
unfortunately I didn't have the
opportunity to to look at the game
together with him afterwards I would
have been interesting to learn what what
he had overlooked him the thing is it's
not yet dramatic for white but he had
spoiled
he has Porter's advantage now there are
ways to be worse of course if whites
play something like this for example
I just play Knight c8 and I pick up this
pawn and there's absolutely nothing as a
compensation for that like it's just
much better yeah what else is there
yeah the Queen trade for example is also
an upgrade I still pick up the pawn with
the night yeah he played the absolute
best movie I played Queen to III not
something that you love to play of
course I mean there's always this check
now to to reckon with okay but what has
this counter ideas okay
next move is easy the only movie night
c8 yeah trying to to get the pawn and it
was the only move anyway the night was
hanging and I had no other square yeah
it here it's the absolute critical
position of this game I mean there were
many of tough positions before and
everything but right here the game is
decided it turns out that YTM has more
than one possibility to to force a draw
basically I let's say keep the position
equal because and it's not a real draw
but it's an equal position there are
some sort of some perpetual possible
though okay what should why do a move
like Bishop f5 is interesting queen Tiye
Queen check I need to I need to check
there no no other possibility
check yeah look look at this yeah white
here has a very serious counter-attack
like this attending Queen g6 checkmate
yeah I can play 94 that's very important
yeah and now for example Bishop d5 is a
possibility that can lead to to a draw
we should take C takes the knight is
hanging yeah if I try to win a piece
check and lose the night and if I take
here chance Queen g6 and this is one of
the one is the pipette
as Blackie's counter threatening very
seriously himself Jack check those
checks needs to be played to to draw
this is one possibility to draw another
one or another interesting move was d7
just jettisoning this pawn Bishop takes
Bishop f5 also interesting to get the
Knight to f5 and this is a position
after rook d8 that the computer Houdini
just evaluates as dead equal probably
seeing perpetual like this Queen c5
queen h7 night is free and we have some
sort of Perpetual however in a practical
game this is still a completely
different matter not quite sure what
would it happen them on yeah the thing
is he played rook air-five and yeah I'm
not sure what he overlooked but this is
not working this move and it's not
working
simply because of night takes t6 this is
certainly some the move that he saw
that's clear but I guess he must have
overlooked something
afterwards I'm not sure maybe rook g5
that he planned loop g5 I'm really not
sure he played a rook rook h5 now maybe
maybe this is what he had planned and he
had overlooked something here I'm not
sure it looks very dangerous at first
but I'm just escaping him yeah like this
I can always go to e6 I'm really not
sure what what he overlooked because 196
is easy and what exactly are you doing
now he played Luke h5 as mentioned and
the curious thing is that it's not like
I only have one winning news I have more
than one winning
now um afterwards to be honest Uruk f7
even looks easier
I played King f7 which is winning but
maybe rook f7 was was even easier
it looks very Luke looks a bit scary
this movement I'm threatening maybe rook
g7 and yeah something like Bishop g6 for
example it's not it's not helping him
much I can go to d7 itself it looks
dangerous but there is no mate simply
and he cannot just just involve the
Queen because I mean he can but it's not
leading to anything because I have this
Queen trade yeah look Luke f7 also was
okay but I saw king f7 and saw that it
wins so I mean no no use in looking at
anything else the problem is I simply go
to e6 and the King is saved there there
is nothing much happening he gave his
check now yeah the alternatives are
mostly checked so this needs to be a it
needs to be examined but I should just
go to e6 there is nothing going on for
example if he now tries this try to pin
you on the six rank I have this check in
an ID form and black will force a queen
trade after which he has a very easy
endgame win with a pawn and not just a
pawn look at this silly knight on h4
which is totally dominated by the bishop
so black is completely winning here also
all pawns are weak of course
so the rook check is also not helping he
gave this check on g6 and well I just go
here and yeah the king is safe what what
can you do he can never ever move the
knight because of Queen G - checkmate
and you know this counter-attack it's
just very very annoying for why she
cannot really accordion
his pieces he played King f2 now after
which there's more than one good move
but at the time what sir yeah was
getting low and I really I really wasn't
sure what's the best continuation after
a while I just decided to take on c4
just grab another pawn I mean the thing
is he cannot play Bishop f5 yes Queen f5
is a very easy win again transposing to
an end game with two pawns to the good
and well as I saw that after Knight c4
he basically must play Queen D 3 there
is no no other move to to prolong the
fight so this is what he did and then I
just hope this was service was bad check
then I gave the check check those checks
that was clear and 96 this was my plan
when I took on c4 because he I'm
threatening Bishop b5 winning and yeah
winning the Queen and I thought that
here he does not have any any attack and
it turned out to be the right judgement
white absolutely has nothing he took his
last couple of minutes to try try to
find something against the King but
there is nothing and yeah at the end he
decided to give this check ok I must
take that and no Queen takes it's very
important that Knight takes is not
helping at all because Queen g2 will
absolutely for sure trade Queens yeah
like this yeah with a check and this is
the reason why it's so easily winning
otherwise Knight f5 with those kind of
ideas would have been very tricky note
that you cannot go here due to Queen f3
which wins the house yeah so he needs to
take with the Queen and now I can just
go to the 6 there is nothing nothing bad
happening he went here yeah if he gives
the check first I can just go over there
and all the way to b6 and the king is
save on b6 there is enough
nothing bad happening yeah this is also
covered by by the Queen on g1 so he does
not even have a check and I'm two pawns
up and I have somewhat take myself so he
really needs to find find a mate or
something very dramatic yeah he tried to
look age seven not just cutting the King
off but gap like black is already it's
too strong here yeah hehe I took awhile
and I couldn't find a win by checking
yeah just checking him and at the end I
decided okay just grab another pawn why
not
I mean I didn't I didn't see anything
bad happening to me so so I took it and
the important thing is that after 96
what he played that I have a winning
line and I need to have exactly this
winning line but I saw that so the check
here King III
and now this is very important now only
one move wins but it is winning so I'm
what I played was okay the key mafia is
Bishop to b5 that's the important point
now threatening Queenie to mate and this
saves the rook the mate red is very very
strong
he has no no check even here or no
meaningful check so he went to went for
c4 and now I had a queen g1 check and I
will be able to capture on c4 with the
check yeah like this yep
Jack this is what happened in the game
yeah he now played a king - king - you
won yes something like that is not
helping I can take here or Bishop a4
they they both win sorry here
yeah and
what exactly is the easiest him hmm
can I go hijo I didn't have this in my
notes on the computer he wants to do he
wants to do this okay yeah it's probably
also winning I mean it's four pawns and
I have the attack yeah he went to he
went to e1 and after that quit e3 is
relatively easy this runs into yeah I'd
direct queen loss so here and now I took
a moment if there is a mate and I didn't
find a mate so so I just took it King
here and Bishop e6 that's the easiest
way to do it
I'm just attacking the Queen he has no
check and if the Queen moves away let's
say here for example I have I have this
check and that will pick up the night
so after here after this Bishop is six
movie he resigned so yeah this was an
absolutely fantastic start of this
tournament of course after the two
initial wins I even managed to win the
third game against this strong
Grandmaster who of course didn't have
one of his best days he I guess miss
term around here we just go back to this
to this critical spot yeah I mean if we
look at this Bishop before was stronger
very tough very tough to play but here
after I committed this mistake when Age
3 he had this opportunity here with with
rook f3 which was very strong and yeah
not easy to see if not easy to see but
the main problem was that he went d6 I
mean he led to win slipper banner
playing [ __ ] f3 but this is still a very
very decent position for why they
is certainly easier for white to play
than for black but d6 really gave it
away in terms of an advantage and then
he M played rook f5 miscalculating
something I'm not quite sure what I mean
I couldn't I couldn't really could
really ask him so um yeah after 96 he
had real attack and in fact it was
blacks a check that was even more
effective at the end yeah so this was
the third consecutive win at the start
and okay it was clear with three out of
three on that in the fourth round I
would get one of the absolute top guys
of the tournament yet - was I think
number eight or nine seat in the in the
event and okay with three out of three
it was clear that I would get an
absolutely absolutely top player but
it's it's tough in those tournaments if
you in this round in the third round
for example Grandmaster Grandda Zuniga
from Peru he's rated to 680 or something
close to 2,700 he lost the game against
a player with 2,400
2,450 or something and it's not not an
easier task to do we know those games
okay so look forward to the to the next
stroke average as in round four I'm
playing and even stronger crank master
then then covered in this game thanks
for watching